[Musique]
là messieurs bonsoir bienvenue à 124,60
hors-série la pire des violences et
celle du silence m'ont invité à briser
ce silence meurtrier la rue le piano la
musique ont même sauvé et ses manières
qu'il a commencé à être heureux il ya
chez lui le petit daniel et le grand dan
ils ont appris à se connaître à se
comprendre à ces mais il se décrit comme
un bédouin et de la tendresse mon invité
dans 10 gr bonsoir
comment ça va reviens pas c'est une
question qu'il faut poser à quelqu'un
qui nous a appris qu'il allait vers une
autre grande épreuve dans sa vie et qui
la traversaient je crois comprendre avec
bienveillance et un succès d'une
certaine manière que ce cancer je ne
sais pas encore je pense mais ce canevas
savoir
plus tard dans l'été voir si tout est
parti ou si au contraire il n'y a de
quoi mais selon les statistiques mon
médecin dit que jésus deux tiers de
chances qu'ils purent y est ça garantit
rien mais je trouve ça trop chaud phone
comme pronostic man ce correct pour moi
ouais mais j'ai terminé un chignon sur
l'instant je suis certain que je termine
jamais où ça fait du bien sur ce contrat
ouais tu m'aimes même fichier un beau
sourire même la vie mais la vie est
devenue bonne pour vous oui la vie très
longtemps qu'elle vit bonne pour moi
mais je trouve spécialement c'est ainsi
parce que c'était et quand j'ai quelque
chose comme un cancer petite tape sa
tête mais monsieur côté de mossur même
en équité - pourquoi moi tu fais pas ça
le jeu ça sous-entend qu'un tribunal
décide qu'ils vont mourir qui vas tu vas
vivre ça sous-entend que tu as fait
quelque chose de mal aussi
c'est quelque chose qui te faire mal
dans ce que tu as à faire d'autres fêtes
devrait occuper mais pas tenir avec
sophie reçoit services y avait de toute
façon un tribunal je le remercierais
pascal chanteur de 60 ans qu'il prenait
un cancer c'est plate mais moi j'ai vu
les enfants st-juste 22-2-1 trois grands
qui allait mourir nous trouvons
maintenant je préfère le juge a tancé
comme ceci dit j'ai très envie de vie
dure
tu dises dit je continuais des projets
mais bon le reste on le suit mais c'est
certain que je voulais faire ça avec
calme tendresse avec moi tous mes
proches
puis avec la vérité aussi tout leur dire
jamais arrêté de me faire des phrases se
trouve dans un patio benali nos premiers
âges les réseaux frappe ça ça a calmé
tout le monde autour de moi un pige pour
tout le monde a bien fait c'est mon
tournoi
mais le public ressort comme favorables
ont fait des jobs et shopi oui le monde
me fiche des cracks au site zataz
je trouve l'idée plutôt sympathique
parce que avec tout ce que vous avez
vécu avec tout ce que vous avez partagé
avec nous depuis déjà plusieurs années
on peut se dire que la mort vous l'avez
côtoyé mais que la vie était plus forte
vous avez écrit la mort fait pas gagner
mais en attendant la vie c'est ce que
plus beau c'est ce qu'a pu faire dans
votre esprit oui c'est à dire que des
personnes dix mortels on va te dit
penser à cette justice mais comment
j'explique mon fils moi j'irais pas dans
les sachets chs ldc inhumé dispose là
dedans alors je m'organisais dessus je
tenais mais je dis pas de suite 6 juin
95 ans c'est là que ça va se passer et
ce à partir aussi j'ai une vie où
j'avais beaucoup de dignité quand
j'étais petit je ne pourrais pas en
avoir
après ça je me souviens une vie digne je
n'aurai pas de moring alors que ça soit
dans deux ans ou dans 30 ans ça va être
la même chose je veux partir dignement
puisse le modifier pour le faire mag est
sorti tout temps c'était notre meilleure
chose se posta meilleur choix pour le
monde mais pour la peau nous faisons
dans nos arénas
fait extraordinaire j'ai pas envie de me
priver virtuose reçu bord d'une petite
rivière j'écris et des chevreuils qui me
regarde pas l'âge est critique dans sa
personne la plus malheureuse a atteint
je boude sur le banc tout comme suit
sauf que là la passion ou l'empathie et
la compassion de dan bigras c'est aussi
ce qui vous fait vivre pour les autres
regarder les autres de s'engager auprès
des autres j'ai mentionné olivier
olivier c'est l'enfant qui vous a ramené
à la maison je les enfants qui vous a
ramené à la sobriété voire de rang du
sable et certainement pour lui en tout
cas je suis jamais vu ni su ni à main
généreuse georges savin ouais mais c'est
le premier qui sait c'est rare que je me
servais des termes anglais mais
analysons un terme dans ton serpent
offre ce sérum oui d'autres maisons ça
peut être à oslo cessé mais on prend le
souhaiteront
je n'ai pas de rouge pour vivre
n'importe où je te contacte à korek mais
d'avoir vraiment rond c'est parce que
j'avais mangé mais mon garçon amour qui
est alors les pieds dans le monde
fantastique que j'aimais aussi fait que
jamais j'entraîne nuit moi je le joue
lac saint jean pour rentrer de nuit puis
le jeu me croizet grimpent à 6 debout
pigenel portes à l'école georges tout
label puis après ça je dormais pendant
qu'à tallinn
mais moi j'étais puma gagner à ce moment
là que je suis fatigué il choisit une
sieste puis tout était parfait puis ça a
été une extraordinaire ma vision est et
comment on apprend être père avec ce
qu'on a vécu un père violent un impair
qui frappe est frappé d'une île qui
touchait une mère qui touchait pas mais
qu'ils aient pas calé mais comment la
presse a perçu plus tard qu'ils aimaient
beaucoup quand même
c'était ma gagne soit on parle des
pièces comme des cordonnier mal chaussé
c'est évident que c'était cordonnier
c'est parce que tu es mal chaussés sans
sauter pour besoins des cordonniers
alors j'ai compris mais beaucoup de
choses que les parents ont vécu les
choses qui sont sortis après le livre
aussi dont secret de famille que mon
père voulait pas qu'ils s'assoient sur
mon père venait d'une ferme [ __ ] tour
et faire des études du passé par les
curistes les jésuites nuit qui a été
agressée sexuellement betty sion alors
je comprends qu'en même temps ça
transformer un expert dans sa pratique
pour les enfants puis les gens qui
souffraient de ces choses là même temps
il y avait un côté noir qu'il prenait un
coup moody's met à sortir aussi mais
j'ai jamais senti un manque d'amour de
mon père de ma mère je laisse anticiper
je comprenais pas être très froide très
fermé mais [ __ ] j'ai compris quand
même beaucoup aussi
je dois beaucoup mais par la musique
écriture toujours j'ai pas plus et sont
très très très loin leur jeter entouré
de tout ça juste que je trouve le moyen
de faire mon existence à mes conditions
à moi il a ma musique c'est mieux sortir
comme je voulais puis tout ce que
j'écrivais parce que votre père vous le
dit ma première fois publiquement acte i
victimes d'agressions sexuelles depuis
règlement en 89 mais depuis plusieurs
années déjà on dénonce les abus sexuels
des frères des pères des prime dans
l'église et et votre père vous a déjà
dit tout ce que l'on porte de honteux à
nous finirons par nous tuer lui celle de
swissmem ans à le tuer lui mord ressort
c'est très très très très triste
j'en parlais avec mon autre réponse
demandée c'est à son large était vivant
son frère et épuisement et je me suis
pas seul à peine de mort aux trousses
infligée tu penses pas quelque chose m'a
plus raide que ça je pense que payer
moins fait que
bats est maintenant c'est comme il ya
plus de punitions puis 15 je me retrouve
à ne plus le punir je ne me punit plus
non plus ça va ensemble sa guerre même
quelqu'un qui est mort de la douleur la
daille ligne de la daps et sa femme
aline puis la colère que j'ai porté en
même temps ma porte à faire des choses a
avancé puis en même temps mais c'est
lourd c'est douloureux
avec l'âge je suis conscient que mon
argent encore des gros combats à mener
les chicanes de coqs ça fait longtemps
que c'est fini c'est aux jeux je
m'occupe pas de ces choses c'est de
l'apprentissage que j'ai eue de mes
parents aussi
ils m'ont appris aussi les belles choses
sur cette affaire en vieillissant témoin
en état de choc qui commence à réfléchir
plus évidemment décrivant le livre j'ai
fouillé beaucoup puis source aperçu que
je retiens beaucoup beaucoup de choses
depuis que je devrais les remercier
aussi
ouais parce que à 60 ans on voit les
choses on les vit différemment qu'à 16
ans quand vous allez occuper la maison
pour la rue à québec et au fond il ya le
petit daniel qui souffrait beaucoup
et le grand dan que je dise en
présentation ayant presque l'impasse
comprendre passé mais pas c'est accepter
cela réconcilie la grande réconciliation
d'abord avec vous même pour la voir avec
papa et maman à suivre oui c'est comme
dédoublement de personnes et les petits
milles pour puisque et autres ig parce
que je souffrais de ce que je fais ouais
mais c'est certain que daniel mangeas
dévoile à l'école monge des voix la
maison moi je les voyais partout mais
c'est près d'un gros dan qui s'est
développée depuis qui est venu mauvais
fait moins de ceux capables ma manche et
physiquement puisque a par moment j'ai
aussi dans un des boss me laisse pas
faire si je pense que j'ai une idée qui
singe latine puis je fais vraiment mon
point
mais tout ça c'est tout ça c'est granier
avec un peu de recul évident ça prend un
peu de recul
d'où le fait que tout ça aussi à amener
dan bigras donc à être un bon père
accueillant événements dans le regard de
son fils aussi faudrait demander mon
fils maintenant quand même même s'il
reste une ville dans notre adresse
beaucoup grâce à mon ex
la mère de mon fils de région pierre
boué qui elle taille en quarts contre
lui à saint justin être donnée bec
sonore mes gosses aperçu de nom c'est
moi qui sait pour qui si j'en fais comme
un fait que j'ai élevé mon fils à coups
de gros bec comme son père mais chose
subissent mais ceux-ci bobek c'était
très important aussi puis moi j'ai
jamais eu à crier mon fils créé après
monfils in demandé posso il faisait des
erreurs et je lui donnais l'information
y réfléchissait puis corrigé en plus
j'étais gorath et d'avoir un fils
extraordinaire probablement beaucoup
grâce à geneviève qui est elle même
signé avec un petit rush prix médecin
dit que ça viendrait pas droit à moins
de vraiment faire d'exercer tous fermé
tout le temps que tb les bénévoles
faisaient toujours ça qu'il monfils est
du genre mais de les financer
mais j'aime bien ça me ferait même maire
présent quand le rugby toupie joueuses
spi toute la belge a pris soin d'elle
pcl et monfils ont changé ma vie c'est
clair on va les bouddhas tendresse nous
faut savoir commun
danon savoir à une brève pause et que
l'on continue reste avec nous on va bien
que ce soit après la pause
[Musique]
m
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
on poursuit notre correspondant avec dan
bigras cet extrait ans jeannie mal avec
le range albert votre garneau ivoula
plus qu une grande amie c'est en 2003
vous n'êtes pas changé d'ailleurs nos
jours où je n'ai pas changé vous parler
des mauvaises nouvelles est est ce que
tout ce que vous avez vécu ça a fait de
vous
cet homme préoccupé engagé inquiet de ce
qui se passe autour de nous c'est à dire
que j'étais plus vite société quand
j'étais petit c'est ce côté reject après
so j'ai trouvé ma société projet
commencé à tenir en hostie ça veut dire
qu'ils craignent qu'en fait c'est
bizarre c'est une image c'est comme si
comme qu'un écart qui menacent et mon
petit frère genève va rechercher je suis
un gars qui peut torturer mon frère
c'est moins sexy ça même chose
l'impression que si je vais pleinement
qu un arrachement beaucoup trop pics à
cause de la corruption de haut vol rim
avait je sais comme la société mon frère
dans ce temps l'eau au bronze autre
juste pour moi personnellement fait que
gilles plus sensible plus la rage
remonte un peu non mais moi younes parce
que la la la la
mais c'est sous contrôle à peu près
parce que j'essaye vraiment que ce soit
efficace
souvent je vais interpeller un
politicien publiquement très fort chez
quand je le fais est ce parce qu'un
espoir secret que on peut se rencontrer
un jour parce que l'on est ce tu veux
qu'ils aient un projet qui aboutissent
ça arrive pas sans qu'on s'assoit même
temps qu'on en discute qui est dû soit
content avant de se lever de table
chaque fois prendre aussi mims tu es
fort chatah soit la personne a négocié
puis je me suis aperçu que mais les
personnes qui font des choses que je
trouve dégoûtant
politiquement ils y ont des enfants tout
le monde mène un combat que tu connais
pas fait tellement d'années soit toléré
un peu fait que j'apprends c'est aussi
alors je prends à différer insiste une
mauvaise politique c'est une chose
on peut se parler quand même parce que
dans le livre le temps des seigneurs
vous parler des politiques aux
politiciens
vu que notre expression politique au
point
il s'achète des politiques au point et
bandes annonces et 20 db annonce qui va
le réaliser mais creuse puis finalement
ils font la même chose c'est à dire qui
ils permettent par toutes sortes de
comportements une classe de privilégiés
200 m encore plus plein les poches et
donc à ce moment l'autre coupé de
trouver d'autres manoeuvres pour
qu'ailleurs on paie de plus en plus d'un
poupon en moins de moins en moins de
services
cependant dans une société comme la
nôtre l'on n'est pas dans la misère en
une économie qui roule puis d'avoir un
seul hôpital ses marques et urgences
paix attend 18 ans se font aucun sens
puis dès des écoles où il ya un
orthophoniste psychologue par quatre
écoles ou est ce qu'il ya des milliers
d'élèves
ça ça veut dire que tu as pu de soins
c'est monstrueux à redire on refuse on
est content de soigner les jeunes
canaris mon agresseur qu'on arrête d'en
fabriquer en aval alors c'est parti
déclare de 15 élèves pour que le prof et
le temps de s'occuper des enfants qui
voient mal piqué donc puisque le caïd
autres canettes 4 par l'école ça ça
serait système d'éducation mais ça ne
l'est pas puisque on regarde comment il
est construit de toute façon ligatus
cours secondaire c'est à dire jusqu'à
large pour fabriquer du chip libre après
ça il faut payer donc c'est les gens qui
ont les moyens et envoient leurs enfants
à l'université du terrain ça crie ça
crée des classes de citoyens on pense
que c'est exister sur les autres c'est
chez nous et des classes de citoyens
dominante pierre des classes le citoyen
2 min et ça ça devrait pas arriver la
domination sans relation perverse et
manson
vous écrivez un moment donné que les
justices vous l'avez vécu découverte en
haïti au moment où on aime y en a même
remis un enfant sur vos genoux
que voulez vous le donner qu'est ce que
je veux me donner je voyais qu'ils
étaient dans ses bras aux pistes d'étape
fait qu'on était dans une vie avait
obtenu place
je sais pas c'était et puis je voyais
qui hurlait plus de madame est ce que je
peux le prendre un peu plus beau que les
enfants parce que je les aime c'est tout
puis le psy arrêtez pas duo libre
williams alors en jeu sur pc pas disant
trimestre contre pour le mondial de thé
je lis prix chantaient mon équipe aux
religions chanter sainte nuit un amant
tranquillement puis 800m
oui grave les sons graves alors les
enfants toujours izem 10 ha de l'abbaye
et puis elle est que j'étais endormi
pour nous faire le voyage comme ça pas
ces mesures donner parce que moi je ma
blonde on allait continuer puisque mon
petit ce que vous lui tout est beau
sourire est ce que vous voulez mais je
vous le donne je n'étais pas capable
devant les moyens pour le soigner et
cette centrale est peut-être le tri plus
tard le petit garçon
pour vous nous avons fait pas ce
programme la frontière avec un enfant
qu'on n'avait pas à la liberté ça qu'on
savait qu'on fait pas le principe
douloureuse affaire les sentiments n'est
plus un site web et douloureux j'étais
obligé de laisser aller la misère comme
ça que je veux aucune solution je
pourrais pas partir et un refuge en
haïti toute façon je n'arrive pas encore
pour que j'étais plus jeune que soi mais
ça tout ça ça a été
douloureux de voir des enfants arrachés
à leurs parents la frontière la
frontière des états unis
trois des seuls en ce moment je veux
trouver moyen d'articuler sur mieux je
trouve ça c'est digne des j'aime pas les
gens qui vont pour un gode wind qui
traitez ram nazis à chaque fois qu'ils
sont pas d'accord ça me fatigue ça c'est
digne des nazis c'est du kidnapping
d'enfants
et puis il est garde la plupart dans des
cages
les intervenants ont pas le droit de les
réconforter ses des enfants dabbagh
alors sans épi et pis c'est pas je suis
c'est tout ça dingue c'est tout
bizarrement une partie d'américa de la
rade et à ces choses-là de moins en
moins là celle-là apportera pose très
difficilement même chez les républicains
mais tout ce qui fait c'est luce naples
il ya encore une base très très très
forte ce qui pourrait gagner sa deuxième
élection samedi clinton oui oui je fais
toujours après s'être frotté d'un petit
buy était à 6 et bleu s'est ému que
c'est quand ça gagne et on barbote son
mec moi c'est des vieux pull mais ces
gens-là ça cdc des gens sur mac qui ont
dépassé douloureux mais qui
qui s'incruste dans une société en
faisant des cochonneries s'est dit
jugeant extrêmement permet à la
perversion c'est prendre dans l'autre
que tu veux en cinq ans des lego que tu
fais et c'est des gens qui ne font que
sont toutes les réussites des grands
pervers
j'ai beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup de
musique allemand qui risque de
déclencher des guerres de guerre en
province les 60 ans est-ce que vous avez
l'impression que notre société est plus
généreuse quand même là quelque chose a
évolué parce que vous disiez il ya des
choses que des individus fonds qui
serait criminel mais collectivement on a
on endure des choses oui sont-ils manic
sont inacceptables je sais de source
d'indignation
oui vous mais on a commencé à l'accès à
accepter l'inacceptable graduellement
petit à petit c'est comme ça qu'on était
ont été nourris par l'inacceptable
toujours un petit peu plus donc un petit
peu plus s'est passé pour se révolter ma
force du petit peu plus à chaque fois ça
n'a fait beaucoup alors qu'est-ce qu'on
parle de répartition des chaises juste
le terme et est épouvantable parce que
c'est pas une erreur de répartition
c'est clairement qu'il ya un trafic de
la corruption de très très haut vol où
il ya des gens qui peuvent se permet
juste les détails les paradis fiscaux
mais qui centaines de milliards qui sont
cachés longpré se refaire une éducation
un système de pitié et ici c'est cette
façon faire lors que je trouve très fait
de rapporter de maladie mentale
quant à 2,7 milliards qui tu fais une
crise parce que peut-on 18,6 degrés très
soignée commencent à dépenser s'amuse on
fait quelque chose d'humain là mais
c'est rendu qu'on m'a donnée alors et
terminent pas leur taxi cash les paradis
fiscaux ça me fait penser à un enfant
qui a tellement des centaines de jouets
qui veut pas partager que les eaux puis
15 dans un placard en place comme soit
malheureux les aux enfants tu as mon
repos tourbains plusieurs fois des
petits amis thème puis faisait du fun à
jouer ensemble plutôt que cache était
joué c'est pas normal mais là quand ça
serait peut-être
tellement d'années ont vieilli avec
l'argent doit assumer nos affaires et
puis les gens qui ont ces pratiques là
peuvent le faire parce que le code
dépouilles de trois mille pages fait
qu'il a est bon et bon fiscale et se
promènent et l a fait pour détourner sur
cette île où elles ont été écrites pour
ça je dois pour surveiller tout un
système qui est en place pour déposséder
le monde normal au profit d'une petite
minorité
et ça ça crée des drames sacré des morts
sacré on s'en rend pas compte mais le
désespoir ça tu gagnes en eau trouble
les gens sont plus capables peuvent
endurer
oui c'est le désespoir qui a fait à
auray moment des faits et vous tuer ou
soutenir vos excès et vous avez
canaliser tout ça vers le refuge
on va en parler je vous dirais que cette
année je suis troublé par des chiffres
c'est assez rare jour pourtant le mind
comptable vous dire qu'à date on a
ramassé 5.8 millions ce soir vous nous
avez donné pour rien ne refuse 450
mandat
[Applaudissements]
si je serre les fesses
[Musique]
le nouveau camp est incertain
si je me représente plus
djalma
tuez moi
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
guingamp
quand je donne
ça
lorsque j'y porte le thème du temps
une chaire à 6 7 1
[Musique]
si tu veux
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et bien entendu chanter cette chanson
merveilleuse de gilbert langevin et on
disait j'espère qu ailleurs nous
pardonne on est seul devant les nuits et
quand je les ai vus julien temps que je
me suis dit voici leur guise
c'est quelqu'un qui a toujours
publiquement au printemps à participer à
des débats et de différentes façons on
était plus jeunes fois avec un portement
mais toujours conviction toujours avec
la l'idée de dire lundi si de défendre
les droits de faire tomber des préjugés
je peux dire attendre que j'ai puisé en
lui une force pour continuer pour
poursuivre la route pour débattre et ça
c'est très très important sauce et la
remercie et puis on marche ensemble
depuis des années alors je souhaite
continuer à marcher les cuivres de
nombreuses années encore france labelle
du refuge qui a su recruter justement
inspirés par l'ange animal de gilbert
langevin je mélangerai que vous avez
laissé un long message sur votre
répondeur
oui j'espère que c'est une période
d'essai tout en jouant des bases saines
mauricie textes moi je t'ai pas capable
de composer sur des textes déjà fait je
le faisais à la rva mais pas comme ça
pierre-marie site animé le racisme on
répondra moi je te souhaite tout ça m'a
pris comme 3 à la poigne et je t'emm aux
dîmes après ça j'ai fait ça à ma blonde
pierre on était quand à mes yeux rouges
tous les deux et quelque chose positive
au-dessus vote se compose à chansons
j'ai déjà fait l jeu lorente hasard que
des arrangements symphoniques toujours
atteinte aux gens tout écrit le pied
joueur j'étais à prague en rire monique
d'après que je me suis payé
on va faire parfaitement pour l'animal
dont gilbert sera fier et il a pu
l'entendre d'avant goût bien dans la
ligne j'étais aux soins palliatifs il
entendait y était vraiment sur ces
derniers jours mais sa belle fille qui
était avec lui je me cherchais un gros
gâteau blaster que je t'avais un triple
et puis il faut pas parler fist encore
jurf et je jouais pour chaque fois je
montais leçon fait que mr a passé un
time qui m'a comme emule bit et i
faisait chef d'orchestre comme sauf cet
avantage pourrait aborder comme faut
d'abord deux mois fait que justin est
beaucoup et puis mon jeu peut-être une
coupe de patients côté je sais pas mais
parce qu'on jouait fort melita compte
envoyer c'est quoi un vrai animal vraie
folie une vraie c'est un délire musical
c'est ce qu'elle dure y écouter au
moment de partir aussi varanges animal
baisse parce que j verts l'avaient
composer ses impôts pour que jerry john
mais en réaction parce qu'ils étaient
forcés et près de gerry qui partait et
puis je voudrais enfin à cause du cancer
d'un demi et plus et et gilbert était
bipolaire et
madani a sorti une phrase tellement
fâché il jouer excusez-moi père dont je
parle de france elle crée ses ballades
qui veulent grimper jusqu'au ciel estime
côté fourchette et poétique que c'est
fou c'est quand même fou alors qu'un
était très déprimée dans ces phases dans
l essca chez les aigles une église un
coin qui pore qui allait écrire c'est ce
que gilbert faisait soins puis et
créhange animal l'envoyer par la façon
qu'on connaît j'en ai fait une première
version puis j'étais là parce que
pendant que j'hérite entraîne parti ait
pu partir chez lui avec les ici mais
notre sort pour gagner un port lan merdy
pêche juste une boîte à malle avec une
petite note sur toi de tout ce que
j'aime bien
après que ça il ya eu un terme à tout
sauf que ça à sa femme françoise et le
temps de respirer un peu un trou
important de me dire que c'est soit
qu'ils écoutaient je me souviens plus
aptes physiquement tu peux savoir le
type était la 7e ligne assad d'installer
le tp tard et l afssa qui écoutait
beaucoup bouleverser sa vie bouleversée
parce que vous aviez su c'est du lien
des gens vous avez perdu trop tous en
avait perdu beaucoup de personnes autour
de votre auto mais mêmes refuge vous en
avez perdu un trop tôt manu vous avez
dédié une chanson à mains nues et ce
lien avec france labelle convient
d'entendre parce qu'il faut y revenir
vous dites qu'elle redonne des outils de
coeur à des jeunes détruits qui ont
l'air broyés puis voulu consacré
plusieurs pages 9 de france et ça montre
aux autres qui sont quelque chose est
quelque chose d'important
oui elle fait partie de votre survie
aussi parce que vous êtes un survivant e
oui j'ai une grosse partie malaisie insu
speedware pas mal car si c'était moi je
n'ai pas l'intention de travailler pour
un refuge moi je voulais dire décline
ce très bon chiffre et disque le monde
l'est me l'achète l'impôt ils l'achètent
pour sar et même jour pour jour bongo
s'entendent pas c'est qu'à me le
demander un financement il veut des
scandales le téléthon qui n'amène coupe
c'est à discuter des chars etc sauf que
là on le commence elle à cette cause me
tient très accablant non je savoure ça
me tente pas là mais simplement dit avec
sa petite voix douce qu tu l'entends je
comprends très bien les deux sens à ce
que sa cause soit toujours refusé de
nous aider toute leur place et jacquet
en organique
j'ai été voir une fois le refuge puis je
sais comme je t'ai formellement
bouleversé mais en même temps bouleversé
de beauté parce que le refuge plein
d'endroits de visa y en a beaucoup mais
c'est un droit de résilience et que
j'étais juge vous et avec vous toute ma
vie bon comme je peux encore l'instant
l'offre pour certains qu'un mot creux de
suite mais là c'est en train de monter
le 28e fou peut-être commence à me
croire un peu je sais pas mais c'est
certain qu'on ont déteint sur l'autel a
beaucoup d'été
sur moi puisque espèce de force
tranquille mais il y avait beaucoup de
sens dans mes affaires puis des fois tu
reve nus les affaires tranquillement
comme ça mais c'était bien décidé ça
change rien position pro ça va et aller
comme cela est la bouche des montagnes
avec il ment avec sa voix pas forte
grippaux mais les montagnes c'est son
refus chez qui le crée puis elle la perd
depuis tout ce temps là et vous êtes aux
excités à l'idée à chaque année près
chose refuge de savoir qu il y ait plus
de jeunes qui peuvent être aidés et en
même temps ce miroir avec les jeunes que
vous côtoyez fallait juger jamais sans
leur faire la morale
vous avez touché le fond du baril
l'alcool la drogue ça fait vous tuez
piste est glauque mais menacé par un
moment j'imagine d'un certain moment le
dage juge le juge
il rappe et revers qui font du mal aux
autres viandes blanches et quelle
humanité derrière mais il faut les
arrêter
jusqu'au quai que la misère qui l'amusé
envolée dit c'est quoi ce raisonnement
de juger jamais jugé mais c'est certain
que le bien que ça m'a fait à moi
effectivement je me retrouve dans
plusieurs jeunes pas cause la rue la
cause du trajet qui mène c'était ça qui
est important
rust est moi j'ai fait le 4ème jeu de
moyennement impressionné j'ai eu
beaucoup de fans monsieur bénard un
joueur de piano j'ai découvert le tilt
le piano comme instrument de
communication c'est un instrument
d'isolement à la maison il faut jouer
cinq six ans personne n'est pas chiche
de traquer depuis juste à l'abri dans
toutes mes harmonique toutes mes
affaires et puis je délirais
gouvernement c'est extraordinaire puis
tranquillement je veux s'aperçut que ces
instruments de communication aux sims et
c'est grâce à à quelques personnes qui
m'ont écouté il déborde avant tant pis
que ça commençait à en avoir un petit
peu plus seulement donner quelque chose
qui est je crois vous vous désole
beaucoup c'est qu'on admire
ce qu'ils ont et des ex drogué des
toxicomanes comme vous avez été mon
continue de mépriser ceux qui le sont
encore c'est un grand jury sud on vous
admire pour ce que vous avez réussi à
faire le premier journée quand on a 15
heures j'arrête un oui mais les autres
qui sont encore pris avec l'alcool et la
drogue
ils sont encore maîtrisé sa puce qui
mais ce qu'on oublie aussi c'est que ce
avant d'être pris dans l'alcool et la
drogue il était pris dans quelque chose
encore pire et c'est pour ça qu'un
terrain drogue et l'alcool c'est un
médicament très mauvais médicament fini
par tuer qui finit par branches et des
vies quand on décroche pas et tout ça et
je ne comprends bien puis ça fait du
saccage même année et rien d'autre
accrochez sourire d'en face je comprends
très bien ce chemin là même aux ennemis
avant la donne qui m'impressionne la
bressaude dans la drogue
mais il ya déjà un début de solution
créer d'autres problèmes
il ya déjà un mouvement par un avançait
que la plupart des gens qui ont une et
gros problèmes de drogues se tiennent
cros majorité s'en sont sortis l'instant
j'ai croisé rue vous présentent leurs
enfants moi sont bouleversées à chaque
fois le coeur à m'arracher mais si on
continue à mal dit comme ça une fois
toutes les deux semaines comme ça
m'arrive m'avait jusqu'à 220 comme ceux
ci c'est ça c'est la plus belle
récompense que tu peux te vraiment c'est
de voir des gens qui ont aidé trajets de
la vie qui sont très très mal parti pour
qu'on leur foute s'essayer dont on se
sert encore la société de termes
épouvantable comme enfant problème
cependant sans problème son enfant qu'il
ait un jour problème que des adultes lui
ont causé qui demande à néré fait citer
qu eux aussi société a causé aux est
parce que j ai par un spa tout des
mauvais parent il ya des parents
débordés il ya des parents qui sont
encore plus dit munich leurs enfants il
ya des fois des parents qui ont cinq
enfants bien et qui prend en charge car
même les eaux vont très très bien et il
n'y a pas toute l'histoire de on peut
pas satisfaire notre imagination en
bande de gaza done so ça marche pas
comme ça
c'est d'ailleurs
la réflexion pourquoi vous avez fait à
l'égard de votre part est votre mère
c'est le site quasi de votre père
pendant des années comme un méchant mais
il ya du bon et du méchant on est humain
on est un enfant on n'est pas qu'une
seule chose au fond non c'est sûr je
deviens un peu fourre essayé de mettre
mes parents les deux dans case des
hosties food en cause du beau monde qui
des bons parents puis il fit pas dans
une cause parce qu'ils étaient l'autre
aussi émané je vois ce aperçu jeudi les
bordels sont humains puis c'est tout
puis je crois sincèrement qu'ils ont
fait ce qu'ils ont pu
malgré la fed signes ont fait ce qu'ils
ont pu
moi je mange comptant dans vos rues les
pas revu même s'ils savaient que j'aime
beaucoup mais par un sujet encore de la
tendresse jeu il ya évidemment ça laisse
des traces
quand je rentrais ça sera pour 1000
cimetière que je serai pas taire et
m'ont transpercé mésandans à l'eau
on tourne et que les poissons sont allés
au début on renvoie les lots mais je
veux pas teinter avec ma famille c'est
je sors donc ça le cinéma mais met quand
même en ce moment sont pose la question
jamais par amis ça prend du temps pour
des maudits le mot pris vite à écrire
parce que j'écrivais comme un fou que
j'ai écrit aux ménages mais parce que je
le comprenais je comprenais mon histoire
je récuse ce livre quand j'aurai
suffisamment compris ma propre histoire
et donc l'histoire de ma famille puisque
ce que j'ai pu remonter jusqu'à la
rochelle mais mais pour m'insulter tard
et d'écrire deux simples tout va jouer
notre envie de tout bois sur une tournée
puis vers à pitre survient deux ans
après tu comprends pas les choses à ma
façon
facture commence dans la silice l'avion
pour tourner la page du commissaire mais
n'a pas moi je tourne livre intime il a
fallu que je recommence plusieurs fois
que c'est ici à la fois très émouvant
bouleversant
il ya des moments où on éclate de rire
et l'humour de dan bigras liste soit
vous avez mais pour revenir à votre mère
vous lisiez j'ai appris avec le temps
que tu m'aimais moi je t'aimerai
toujours ton bien oui c'est ce que je
change ma vie j'ai de la haine quand
même tâche contacts et les deux ainsi
des mix finning sculpteur le chemin
monsieur je suis très très touché j'ai
oublié sur tous sommes effectivement
j'aurais mis ma mère toute ma vie sur
quelqu'un m'a déjà dit on est du pays de
son enfance
oui et puis le
parler d'eux
le truc de société que j'ai avec la
société hippique c'est doris lucie
qu'ils aient news la patrie c'est la
famille des familles puis surtout au
québec parce que moi j'ai remarqué sa
maman d'anne et vin chaud frein coup
d'or puis donc à madany lillers et des
palissades simplement playmate sauter
dans rue afin de chaussures chez vous du
jeu vidéo centre-ville l'installa donc
je rentrais à pied mais jean aussi élevé
60 mille personnes qui rentraient chez
eux et je suis rentré en marchant dans
le public
faut qu'ils aient salue d'un nouveau
bond fund profond de soi régime agir
lorsque j'ai moi je vis la pige musique
ou ailleurs qu'au québec qu'on peut
faire ça en france d'un possible les
gens connus ont besoin de baudet gold
aux etats unis aussi parce qu'il est
vrai mais les fanatiques qui sont
déséquilibrés mais ici il n'ya pas ça
c'est certain que 6 juin d'un rapport à
2 heures du matin tout le monde est
honteux pour ma face à challes un peu
mais c'est à moi choisir mes affaires
c'est mais que tout puisse rentrer chez
vous le mieux ton pull et moi s'appelle
plus belle illustration que cette
épreuve adaptée comme un petit cousin
puis lointain car mon logement je t'ai
pas un mot non clos mais la même chose
non langue française au québec pour le
veulent
programme française oui je suis inquiet
pour ce parce qu'un mandat une période
de ma vie où il ya une solution qui
était concrètes que d'autres avaient
développé puis qui est en train de
passer piste est de faire la séparation
du québec on soigne république qu'on
soit un pays
et puis sur c'était la grande solution
qui fait d'un milieu à d'autres
solutions après h embarqué à fond là
dedans puis je serai séparatisme du
kosovo ni séparatistes pinet parents
étaient membres du jury en avant fait qu
assistant c'est gravé dans mes gènes et
un peu cette affaire là je me suis
aperçu que c'est à ce prix qu'on fasse
jour la souveraineté avec des gens qui
sont aussi connecté avec la finance de
haut vol puis qui font de la corruption
il faut régler ça et si c'est pas
québécois c'est mondiale dans des
dictatures ça fonctionne façon pin en
démocratie parce qu'on vote aux quatre
ans on pense qu'on a plus notre mot à
dire
où est on là à dire des fois mais
surchauffe pour grand chose des choses
qu'ils veulent pareil d'art société
dannon continuer après la pause je reste
avec nous dans des gras a certainement
encore beaucoup de choses à nous et ça
va le laisser à tous
[Musique]
de la dame en bleu
on poursuit la conversation avec dan
bigras j'oserais dire le rassembleur dan
parce que dans l' isolement dans cette
violence qui isolait d'une certaine
manière qui dans un silence avec la rue
les bandes au fil des années en les
groupes la musique crée son mur avec le
refuge depuis tant d'années qui
rassemble et c'est une nouvelle famille
aussi pour dan bigras pour toujours il
ya beaucoup d'anciens tout seul qui
deviennent des mots assemblage pas ce
qu'ils font pour eux c'est normal c'est
ce que j'ai fait ici j'avais besoin de
ces gars là j'ai besoin construire
l'ensemble qui crée ton travail
j'accueille jamais monde et des membres
de mon équipe ça arrive pause paris les
affaires parce que oui ta famille on
sait très bien ces milieux
professionnels mais l'on est affaibli
pour le typhon qui j'avais qu'on peut
pas dire non à dan bigras parce que de
mettre ensemble éric lapointe que michel
louvain au damier alys robi où j'ai
tellement ri parce que j'ai pas vu ce
texte-là du refuge de l'élu oui j'ai
beaucoup de moments dans le livre où on
en a le cancer et il est mort le 4 e
place comment pied d'autres mamans ils
seront dix qui ont fait leur de rire j
véhicules de la pointe michel louvain
était allé se glisser dans la peau inpi
lourd et c'est que je me dise si ça
marche parce que j'ai été manipulé un
petit peu avec leur consentement car
ayant norway avec leur consentement
puissent s'adonner je me dis ça va tu es
maudit bon nombre au pire finalement et
arib le répéter pis on était tout
bouleverser nier cela on peut tout
toucher c'était cet apport c'est quelque
chose de très très volume mj comme soit
inexplicable
[Musique]
saleh
buffon
[Musique]
une labels a retenu
[Applaudissements]
gore
mais les côtés comme examen il vient
d'apprendre que j'ai une vie drôles
aussi je sais je passe mes diplômes et
sausset c'est ma protection mais j'ai
j'ai pas arrêté de me tordre de rire moi
toute ma vie moi je joue avec un band
américaine m'a donné pour 2 juin à new
york à new york une telle compétition il
n'ya pas notre vie s'est fait rejoindre
abitibi en gaspésie mais au moins on
retravaille et c'est correct se promener
pour votre travail et un bon guitariste
bob de yuto qui parle est tellement mal
français pts qui voulait tout le temps
commander lui même n'est resté en piste
vraiment donné on a une récente d'alltel
et restaurants la hausse de 6,7 à la
main la piste des cds grosse serveuse
qui avait tout vu tes impressionné
personne s'il y avait tout vu dans leur
vie typique de terre cuite rsa et puis
comment il fallait tout tout tout ce qui
se passe à voter jusqu'à ce qu'elles
disent déçus comme un drop
c'est tout moi c'est des affaires comme
ça j'en ai 60 par jour tout le thème
avis comique aussi on soupçonne pas je
suis je fasse un nom se sentent pas il
reste que pour l'avenir d'anne qu'est ce
qu'on à quoi on rêve quand on a écrit
des phrases comme quand le coeur souffre
le corps clair je suis toujours curieux
de savoir ce que faisait ce mal à sa
tendresse c'est des phrases tout le long
des phases très poétique très belle
alors parce qu'avec ce livre on arrive à
dessiner l'avenir et d'une certaine
façon et découvrir la poésie pour moi
c'est une façon d'assumer lapsus c'est
que je ne veux pas les hippos dire
quelque chose puis le divorce avec moi
quand j'écris par exemple ici ça devient
plus poétique c'est moins des récits
corps il ya quelque chose qui s'échappe
de moi un peu sans mon consentement donc
fallait que j'y aille
avec ce pour ça que j'aime beaucoup
cette écriture le puits que puis que ça
me fait du bien
maintenant chaque projet comme une
espèce dans ma taille d'une espèce
d'audition que je me donne à moi même
pour l'approcher
dis moi je prends un gode de carrière
chez un gode j'ai un projet est d'abord
ce qu'il faut j'ai toujours cas je suis
une des figures au déficit d'attention
donc dans mon ordi gk proche des adultes
a plongé qui doit inscrire dans l'autre
et moi il y en a un qui prennent d'avant
ce lot je le finis brossage proposons
c'est comme ça que ma vie c'est moi je
sais écrire et faire de la musique je
suis déjà extrêmement privilégié d'avoir
filiale c'est pas tout le monde qui peut
cesser une sale période bien qu'ils
l'aiment à cause que fait détoner cause
des choses c'est une très très belle
vivre parce qu'au début
vous avez toujours douté de écrites sur
moi même au début vous vous voyez un
gros monsieur noir ces jouets 2011 que
vous êtes devenu un petit mot sur un
grand monsieur blanc inspire mais ses
droits rien d'impossible ans qui joue
des tonnes et donc mais j'étais loin sur
noir pendant presque 7 un journal et
barça c'est parce que je n'aimais pas
enchanté moi je te la chambre je l'avais
vue et mais qui tous piano-bar pied mais
gros monsieur noah qui rentrait j'adore
6 ans atteint je sais pas et puis d'un
match a été joué là d'un vrai vie à la
première bien mais dans la ma tête et
jouer la puissance était ce à cinq mois
les enfants les rêves d'enfants faut que
ce soit reçue ces boucs des rêves c'est
ce qui m'a sauvé la vie j'aurais pu
faire vivre ces professionnels puis ce
qui m'a sauvé c'est que je rêvais mais
faut que les règles soient reçus
quelques pas avec moi un enfant qui est
un rêve farfelu joindre à sec des plumes
des aurès et aubry go mais peut-être
qu'à sa gueule il voit son avait offert
ses affaires mais mais il va pouvoir
réaliser son rêve parce que plus on rêve
adelin bizarre puis personnel dont
plusieurs chances de marcher ensuite
rêve bizarre ça dépend de ce que tu
tiens pour moi c'est si tu sais quoi et
rêve dix ans c'est devenu comptable si
ça fait peur
dans ma tête j'ai pas ça vous quand son
retable
non non j'en ai parlé à ma comptable ça
l'à beaucoup fait rire parce qu'elle est
passionné de son métier c'est juste
qu'on n'est pas faire pareil sur ces
choses et puis de toute façon faut
travailler ensemble c'est ce qui fait
qu'on une société oui en même temps de
raconter parce que dans le livre c'est
aussi et le 10 pouces qui vient parce
qu'en même temps le temps des seigneurs
au fait c'est qui le meilleur c'est
l'airé paru chez les hébreux pour moi
moi mes seigneurs à moi si les
infirmières pingre les les seigneurs
pour moi c'était dans le temps ceux qui
appuyaient le roi pour percevoir les
taxes droits spoliés une belle cote
la famile peuple et sont encore là
maintenant et ses deux autres je parlais
au départ laisse y faisant suite à ce
livre j'appellerai le temps des aidants
parce que ça existe ou sinon donc
nettement demain des gros gros gros
défauts mais je sais la faillite de très
belles choses qui sont si vous avez
croisé des gens qui vous ont été à
travers la maladie l'ont dit que ça va
bien mais le système de santé quand même
père pour moi j'étais très très chanceux
que je n'arrivais à l'urgence de ces
lieux que je te plier en deux puis dans
ce sens la cat et pierre deux pixels
vente
il nous explique ensuite que je pense
était stoppé dix jours après avec moi
j'étais piste et aux chômeurs qui avait
encore personne chez tous les étages qui
modifient champ de picasa peut être
déprimant moussin modique on ose tout le
monde nous et vous tendiez dressé je
sais médiation et ce qui est très dur
c'est de rentrer d'un système de santé
telle allure gens soit en montant une
fois qu'ils prennent en charge
moi j'ai dit super pris en charge et par
mon médecin et mon infirmière pivot que
je remercie épi partout d'infirmiers et
infirmières qui était leur usure sont
tout le temps un petit travail point la
personne qui s'imagineraient quel point
times donc vous êtes un survivant à
plusieurs types souffrant du cancer
survivants de tout ce qui a un vécu mais
si on devait se laisser sur une
réflexion c'est vous qui l'avez fait
il est là dedans la violence de
l'abandon la violence du silence aussi
parler chanter écrire ça fait du bien
vous laissez faire avec les risques qui
viennent avec sa famille qui dit ça
qu'ils en pensaient mais encore lors de
ma famille qui m'ont sait bien parler et
puis c'est correct mais mais c'est clair
que moi j'allais m'en sortir par le
silence je portais trop de choses à
l'éclaté qui cartonne éclate on peut en
mourir aussi
alors mettez pas question de survie
était question que les choses soient pas
ce que je dis pas ce que je sais moi je
suis des affaires monstrueuses
non mais je ne vais pas aussi bien sur
le toit par exemple quand tu vas au lieu
des conséquences d'autres pas assure-toi
puis je préfère mon fils li était comme
ça à 5 1 il défend des sons queen de
façon logique et puis tout cela puisse
surfer que ce soit mais c'est certain
que le silence le silence est complice
de beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup d'horreurs
pas ce moment là par notre science on y
conclure nous mêmes aussi douce - y
compris logements
je voudrais pas être à sa part alors
dans des grands mercis on lit le temps
des seigneurs absolument bouleversant
des moments drôles ou 6000 bouleversant
long chemin long chemin est difficile ce
n'est qu'ils s'expriment en chansons et
en musique
merci beaucoup tb merci ou une petite
tutoiement
[Rires]
[Musique]